it's the first time in six years that
officials at this level
have met libya's internationally
recognized government in tripoli
the visit of the egyptian delegation to
tripoli was carried out by prior
coordination between the foreign
ministries of the two countries
the delegation was responsive and
positive in the talks
based on today's meeting we will witness
the development and the diplomatic ties
with cairo
the relationship between cairo and the
government of national accord
was cut in 2014 and around that time
president abdul fattah sisi of egypt
began supporting
war lord khalifa hafter who held
dominance in the east
in april 2019 with egyptian support
hafter began a military offensive on
tripoli
the gna asked turkey for help and with
ankara's support
gna forces successfully retook western
libya
in june but not before residential areas
a field hospital and an immigrant
detention center
were shelled the attacks drew
accusations of war crimes
the visit by the egyptian delegation
comes only a day after a visit by the
turkish defense minister
and senior military officials ankara has
military experts on the ground
and are training gna forces
it seems there's a political settlement
and this visit by the turkish defense
minister yesterday was not a coincidence
libya is increasingly becoming important
regionally and internationally
egypt may now feel that they've lost a
major partner in tripoli
or it may be that they now support a
political settlement
some believe the visit by the egyptian
delegation is a step in the right
direction
we need to ensure that the international
community
remains united but also that key players
like
egypt and turkey are conveying messages
to the parties that they sponsor to tell
them
compromise inclusivity reconciliation
among libyans
rather than launching new and separate
initiatives
the united nations is also working to
build trust between
western and eastern libya the rival
sides agreed to hold
elections next year but they have so far
failed to reach an agreement on the
shape of any new government
although there is some anger over the
visit by the egyptian delegation
many here believe the normalization of
ties between tripoli
and cairo may help fuel a political
settlement to the years-long conflicts
malak trainer al jazeera tripoli